[Music]
fifty years ago this week
moviegoers got their first look at the
sci-fi epic 2001 a Space Odyssey
director Stanley Kubrick and science
fiction author arthur c clarke teamed up
in creating the visionary film
a new book by author Michael Benson
entitled Space Odyssey published by
Simon & Schuster a division of CBS looks
at the making of the film and its four
year-long production process we're still
talking about 2001 50 years later
because for one thing the film deals
with four million years of human
evolution and it also seems to encompass
the visible universe one of the most
ambitious projects in any medium in the
last 50 years 2001 is regarded as a
masterpiece today but the initial
reviews were mixed some critics even
slammed the film as incomprehensible and
self-indulgent but the public loved it
and ultimately it became 1968 top
box-office draw while it was released a
year before man landed on the moon 2001
predicted current technology like
FaceTime
iPads weeks ago even screens on the back
of airline seats the film also deals
with themes such as human evolution
space exploration and the perils of
artificial intelligence depicted in the
film by a murderous computer named Hal
open the pod bay doors hell I'm sorry
Dave I'm afraid I can't do that the
battle really between the human and the
artificial intelligence you know calls
to mind for example some of the warnings
we're hearing lately from Elon Musk you
know and the late Stephen Hawking about
what might happen when we have a truly
sentient artificial intelligence I'm
sorry Dave that voice because haunt you
we both just said yes the Elon Musk the
same warning that they had back then are
the ones that we hear now about
artificial intelligence and like you I
was confused by the Dom tells me you
have to read a book you understand it
we'll get to that after this